hi
welcome everybody um we are delighted to
uh to see all of you
um attend this animal uh which is the
second event
in the series of how to join the quantum
workforce my name is florian carl i'm
the manager of the yale quantum
institute
and i'll be one of the moderators for
this panel
we are delighted to continue this series
which is organized jointly by the
engineering workforce development of the
center for codom network in arizona
and the yale quantum institute in
connecticut so this is
on the second panel and today we are
focusing on how to prepare for grad
school
we wanted to offer this panel since
building quantum technology requires
a lot of people with different
background we need physicists we need
electrical engineer we need computer
scientists
software engineer chemist and it can be
really overwhelming to consider a
carrier in quantum information
so today we will hear from grad students
and grad school administrator and dean
and what it's like to work in quantum
and get advice on how to navigate
the different the various pathway to do
a career in the field of quantum science
and information
i would like to introduce my colleague
russell balliet who is the assistant
director of the center for quantum
network and will serve as
a co-moderator and so i will let him
introduce himself briefly before we
welcome our panelists
yep so thanks lauren so like said i'm
the
assistant director for engineering
workforce development for the center of
quantum networks a lot of you
are already familiar with me um and i'm
also managing a couple so
summer programs this year ru's and ret
so i'll be moderating as well and might
chime in with my
graduate school stories thanks lauren
so before we introduce the all the
panelists today
some technical details for the panel so
this event is recorded
and will be available on demand on both
of our institute's
youtube channels um only the panelists
can talk
and so you are able to answer to ask all
your questions in the q a
panel underneath you have two speech
bubbles if you click on it you can ask
your question and we will
take this question in priority um and
then
since we cannot we cannot see you we
want to learn a little bit more about
you so
um we should have on your screen uh a
poll that just popped in so feel free to
answer that
and that will allow us to target our
conversation
um to have uh to answer most of the
question and see who's the
the audience today okay so moving on
um let's uh welcome our panelists um you
can turn on
your webcams and we're gonna start the
introduction
um so let's start by um let's do emily
do you want to introduce yourself so you
can talk a little bit about yourself and
what why you wanted to go into the
quantum fields and what it's like to be
in grad school
okay hi i'm emily van milligen i'm
a fourth year graduate student at the
university of arizona
where i'm currently getting my phd in
physics
i work in cycad guha's quantum photonics
applications group
he's actually in the optics department
which is nice because at the u of a
you're encouraged to work with
professors in different departments than
what you are in and i
primarily focus on studying the behavior
of quantum networks
so i've been interested in
quantum mechanics since i went to
undergrad at tufts university
and so i really enjoyed my undergrad
classes and i just knew i wanted
to take more i didn't really know
if i loved research or what i wanted to
do i just knew that i wanted to continue
on to grad school because i wanted to
learn more about the field and see what
opportunities were out there
and it was a really nice
fit going to the university of arizona
because
at least in the physics department they
give you
a couple years to jump around groups and
find your actual fit so it's very
flexible
and it's nice because as
i was working towards completing my
masters taking my classes
i was getting to sample all these
different groups
and i found my home with
professor scicat and i really
enjoy working with him i think it's fun
because
the whole quantum world like plays by a
different
set of rules than like the world we
interact with on a day-to-day basis and
so
that kind of just turns everything into
a giant puzzle for me
so um it's it's not really so much work
as it is like
fun
thank you do you want to go next
sure uh hi everyone my name is connor
han i am a uh
well no longer a graduate student at
yale university i actually just defended
my thesis
a couple of weeks ago so i just finished
up after five years at yale
i was advised there by professor steve
girvin
and also co-advised by professor liang
jiang at the university of
chicago so my my journey into quantum
was
perhaps a little bit more meandering i
definitely didn't know starting out
even that i wanted to do physics let
alone quantum information
when i started my undergraduate at duke
university i actually thought
i wanted to go be a medical doctor but
lo and behold there were no
spots available in the first year bio
class and so i took physics instead and
then from there i uh you know
realized that that was a subject i think
i liked a lot more so i kept taking
physics courses and so on and so forth
until i found myself in quantum
mechanics in my junior year
and once i'd taken quantum it was really
kind of a no going back moment i sort of
tried to shift my research
uh interests in that direction and learn
more and more about the field
but um even by the time it came to apply
to graduate school
i'd done some research broadly in the
field of quantum physics but nothing
with respect to say quantum computing or
quantum information
and so it really took me even into grad
school to to learn a whole lot about the
uh the field of quantum computing where
i now have done most of my research
and i spent you know maybe a year or so
thinking about trying out different
groups
at yale and figuring out what would be a
nice fit for me but
i was really happy ultimately to wind up
in in the groups of steve girvin and
liang jiang because
for me one thing that i really value in
my research is feeling a close
connection to
practical applications in the real world
and so this is something i felt with
quantum computing you know i could see
the
tangible potential impacts of the work i
was doing on the day-to-day it felt more
you know in touch with developing
technology and things like this so
for me that's always been a nice aspect
of working in the field and something
that i've really enjoyed
and more broadly yeah i've had a really
fun time studying quantum it's been a
really exciting subject
to pursue my phd and i'll be excited to
continue researching in the field
afterwards thanks a lot
and you want to go next sure my name is
anne galen
i'm an associate dean at yale and my
portfolio
is contains a lot of things but um i
work with
our graduate programs on policies
curriculum
and annual reviews for about 40 of our
phd
programs i also work directly with the
faculty heads of the graduate programs
what we call the directors of graduate
study
and i also work with some of our
graduate programs on the admissions
process so
um i'm here first of all i'm not here to
talk about quantum
i know nothing about quantum so uh i
will defer
to the others on the panel about that
but i'm really here to
answer any general questions you might
have about graduate school
and some of the things you might want to
ask me about are what should i be
thinking about or preparing
in order to apply if i've decided to go
why
might i want to go to graduate school
what makes for a good
application what should i know
once i get here um you know how do you
navigate what some people call the
hidden curriculum of graduate school
and what kinds of assistants either
financial or otherwise are available
in graduate school to help me achieve my
goals and succeed in
whatever i've come to graduate school to
learn
so i'll stop there and look forward to
hearing your questions
thank you um so i we can start by
uh closing the poll and i can also share
the results and we see that
everybody is very interested in uh
having
like in stem career which is great for
us however
we have like a moderate understanding on
like the information on the carrier so
that's perfect because we're gonna be
able to
to help you figure out if going to grad
school is uh
the right move for you there's there's a
ton of uh of way to join the quantum
workforce
and you can also see that all the panels
that we have in this series
will go from enrolling to grad school to
do
a professorship um but also joining
industry joining a startup
and we also have alternative carriers so
um there's way more coming up
um so we're gonna start by
um uh to address your first question um
and i think it's uh we're gonna ask that
to emily and connor
um what it's like to to work in a in a
research group so
you join to go to grad school um it's
it's very different than undergrads
because you don't really
join a school per se you don't have that
it's not a curriculum of classes you
have some classes for their master's
degree but you also
join a research group what it's like to
work in the research group and
how did you pick the groups and can you
share your experience on your your
day-to-day activities
i can go first um so
it's been a little strange for me
because
when i joined the group i'm currently in
um like the next semester covet hit
so a lot of it has been
you know remote over zoom just like
this panel so um
it but in a way it's been really cool so
even though i haven't had been able to
get to know everyone in my group
because it is a large group with like a
lot of different interests
i've gotten to know some people very
well who have
are studying similar things to me but
then i also get to meet
um lots of professors and students at
other
universities and so it's almost like
they're in my
group because we're all working on the
same stuff
and so like a standard week for me would
be like
working with professors at like umass
amherst or
mit and nau because uh
it's the center for quantum networks is
really great where they really
uh like emphasize collaboration so
um that's really it's really interesting
and so i enjoy getting to work with
these professors
and then other graduate students and
i even get to work with undergrads which
is
exciting um and i think that as an
undergrad
i was very intimidated um when i was
working in a lab i was like
intimidated by my superiors and now i
realize that
um like we're all just like on this
pursuit to you know further the field
and so
and like people are going to respect my
ideas
uh just as much and like i actually am
contributing
um so that's exciting
yeah i can jump in and say a couple of
things about my experience as well
um maybe you guys should qualify what
i'm going to say by pointing out that of
course
different research groups are going to
have wiring different kinds of
environments so a lot of what your
experience is going to be like is going
to depend on
the professor you might choose to work
with and how that professor runs their
group and what kind of atmosphere they
foster
um so to say a little bit about my my
own experience i'm a uh
a theorist so i don't do any experiments
myself i wouldn't be any good at it
but i like doing pen and paper
calculations and simulations
and so what that means for me and my
research group on the day to day
is you know maybe about two-thirds of my
time in any given day is devoted mostly
to
my own work either reading papers
working out problems running simulations
this kind of thing but
you know that maybe remaining one-third
of every day is usually collaborative
work either meetings or working out
problems with other people
and it's probably that portion of the
day that i think is the most fun those
will be the times when i'll chat with my
research advisor we'll try to
brainstorm ways to get around
challenging aspects of problems or i'll
work with other people in my group and
discuss topics that we're all interested
in or attend seminars
or do other things i think similar to
emily one of the the really
nice aspects about uh being in a phd and
getting to study interesting problems is
that oftentimes it really is a very
collaborative effort
so not only do i have a number of people
within my own research group that i'm
working with at any given time there are
also
other people at other groups within the
university and at
other universities still so having a
very
nice and collaborative research
environment has been a really valuable
thing that i've really appreciated and
one aspect of my my research group that
i've really liked
another thing i think florian you
mentioned how i you know people wind up
choosing different research advisors
one one thing for me that i think was
really nice is i um in chat
potential advisors i i placed a premium
on being able to
communicate effectively with my advisor
and really get a good sense for
you know not only what they were
interested in but feel like we could
have an easy and free exchange of ideas
and
that sort of thing and that's been
something really nice that
has helped me a lot in my phd feeling
like i was always on the same page as my
advisor we could work very well
and effectively together and so that's
something about
my own particular research environment
that i've really appreciated
well thank you both and to follow up on
that we have a question in the chat um
what led you
are to choose your respective grad
school what was the
you sort of like sort of hinted at like
how you picked your groups but like
why uh why the different school and like
what made you go to undergrad school
uh well for one reason it was uh one of
the places i got in
but um she's a very valued yeah
but um i would say that like the best
thing about
like i think for me like going to the
university of arizona was
the flexibility i was given at the
beginning so
i don't feel like i am um behind because
i didn't
go in knowing which group i wanted to be
in and so that actually gave me time to
feel it out and see um who i thought i
would work well with
so that was a really nice for me
but i do know others like colleagues who
kind of you know had to choose their
group before they went to grad school
and maybe then they've realized that
their advisors
are not everything they were looking for
in a mentor
but the nice thing is that off even in
those cases i think that you can find
someone else like whether it be a post
stock or like another
um because you're collaborating with so
many people you can always find somebody
to help
fill the needs that you have but i
i did like how going to the u of a gave
me the time to like
in person feel out groups and see what
research i wanted to do
yeah and in my own case i actually
i wound up applying to a large number of
graduate programs because i was applying
uh together with my girlfriend now
fiance and we wanted to try to go to the
same program so we tried to maximize our
chances and apply in many places but
so i had a couple of programs that i was
looking at and all of them
seemed like they would have great
research opportunities cool things in
quantum so
for me a lot of the decision between
those programs came down to
some non-academic factors too well maybe
first i should say with regards to the
academic factors one
sort of prerequisite that i used as a
filter to try and determine what
good programs might be is not only what
did i want to be able to identify
a advisor at each of the potential
candidate programs someone who i had
talked to and thought i could work well
with
i wanted to make sure there was more
than one such advisor at each of these
places
because you never know you could go work
someplace and find out that
you know that group isn't really the way
it appeared maybe it's not a good fit
for you after all
and you don't want to be you know stuck
out without a research group where you
feel like you would be a good fit so
having some place where it seems like
there are a lot of groups that you could
work nicely in and see yourself
thriving and having a nice tim time in
at least for me was
an important factor in my decision
another thing that
that in my case was kind of a deciding
factor for yale was i thought it was a
really nice
environment among the graduate students
so in going and visiting the program and
getting to talk to the other students
everyone's seen by and large well i
should say physics grad school can be a
stressful time for sure but people seem
by and large happy
despite the stresses that are inevitable
in a graduate program and
you know people weren't massively
overworked they weren't working 100
hour weeks or anything crazy like this
you know it seemed like an environment
where
not only did people go and learn physics
and do exciting research but they also
enjoyed it while they were doing it and
there was a nice
physics graduate student community that
i wanted to be a part of so
you know the i guess the the takeaway
from this being that you know it's
totally fine and i think important to
consider also non-academic factors
uh when looking at a graduate program
thinking about the kind of life you
might have
there because of course you know five
six or however many years
it takes to do a phd is a is a long time
and you want to think about all the
different things that might contribute
to your quality of life while you're
there
you want to um chime in on explaining
like uh
how people can like if you have general
advice on like how to pick your grad
school
like why they should choose a certain
let's go like what are the
what are the options for for people and
why they should choose certain grad
school what are the criteria's
that perspective students should choose
or should look for at least
um i think what you want to do is
first think about why you want to go to
graduate school what do you want to
accomplish
do you need a graduate degree as connor
said um
graduate school it's a it's a long time
five years
for many degrees sometimes six if you
encounter some roadblocks or
something you need to switch advisors
so you really want to make sure that
it's the thing for you
and what do you want to learn because
what are the questions that
really excite you um it you know quantum
is interdisciplinary so what are the
are there a number of people or
approaches to quantum that you might
want to be
investigating i think uh emily talked
about the fact that she's been able to
explore
and uh you know especially if you're
coming straight out of
undergrad you may not be 100 sure
of what about quantum is appealing and
so a place where there are a number of
people whose research looks
interesting to you is going to be very
important
another thing to to be thinking about is
what do you hope
to do when you finish a degree and i'm
not saying that to scare you you
shouldn't have your life planned out but
um are you really interested in pursuing
research
um are you thinking about um maybe
teaching high school
are you thinking that you want to go
work in industry and different
kinds of um careers
often um require a different kind of
training
and so if you're thinking uh you know i
love physics
i like the idea of quantum but i'm
really thinking when i
teach high school you may not need to
get a phd a master's degree might be
enough
um what about funding you know do i have
am i independently wealthy most of us
are not
but um graduate school the nice thing
about most phd
programs is you don't pay for them
they pay you to study conduct research
and teach and that's something that some
students don't know that master's
degrees you usually have to pay for out
of pocket or take out loans
but phds usually if it's a
research institution of
some repute through a combination
of uh teaching and research you won't be
paying for your degree
and so that's something to be thinking
about too and then
um you know i think the most important
thing is what kinds of questions are the
ones that you're most interested
in that'll help you and your
undergraduate advisor should be able to
help you identify
some programs that might be a good fit
for
your interests you'll want to
look up some of the faculty at the
places you're thinking of
and see what their specializations are
and i'm sure that connor and emily can
weigh in on this that you
you know as connor said you don't want
to put all your eggs in one basket you
want to make sure that
there's uh as because research interests
do
evolve are there two or three people you
might be interested in working with
i see in the chat that there's a
question about how do you reach out to
advisors at programs you're not yet
accepted in
or involved in and one place to start
would be the director of graduate
studies or the director of graduate
admissions
every program has at least a director of
graduate studies
um some programs because they're large
enough have a director of graduate
admissions and so you
could say to them i'm really interested
in your program
these are the things that are
interesting um
and i'd love to talk to professor x or
professor y
so if you're not or or i'm really
interested in
x and y i'm not sure which of your
faculty are the ones that i might want
to contact
but um can you tell me about your
program um so that's one way
to um start that process
if you've read something of someone's or
you have heard or your
undergraduate advisor says to you you
know giving your interest you might be
interested in going to the university of
x
and working with professor y then you
can just
write an email to professor y and say
dear professor y
um my undergraduate advisor i mean i've
been
getting a degree in physics or
computer science or mechanic
engineering um and my advisor
i'm interested in graduate school my
advisor told me that your research
um is very much in line with the things
i'm interested in exploring
uh would you have some time to speak to
me
and now we can do that virtually if
you're local
you want to go try and go visit so you
could actually meet them i think emily's
point about
understanding the community you're
trying to join is really
important um but you really want to be
um doing your homework so that you can
figure out what are the places that
might be a good
fit for what you want to accomplish
and and once you pick your grad school i
know that's uh yell has that and i'm
sure the mr or
not has it too um there's something
called rotation or circulation and so
you pick a group for one semester and
sort of a trial
um conor and emily can you have you done
this have you
taken the opportunity to do this and um
did you switch did you stay with the
professor
what were your experiences with that
yeah so i switched around the first
three semesters
um at the u of a it's uh you can take
independent studies alongside your
classes and so like that's common is
that you take
two classes and your independent study
up until you have like your master's and
that independent study will just be
you working with a different group
and here it
was you would be it was nice because
you're getting funded through your
ta initially so you if you are not
enjoying one of the groups that you're
in it doesn't put a ton of pressure on
you to like
have to get certain results and things
like that uh
for like any funding purposes but um
yeah so i started off in um
like a nuclear theory
uh group and then the next semester i
went into a biophysics lab
and then i realized nope i would much
rather be a theorist
so then i went back to what i knew i
loved and
i joined the quantum photonics
applications group which
it was nice and i chose it because um
they have experimentalists in it and
they have theorists and they have
everything like
in between so i figured i could probably
just spend the rest of my time in this
group and try out
everything i want to my heart's content
yeah i'll just chime in and quickly add
that i think i had a pretty similar
experience to emily at least within the
physics department here at yale
there isn't a formal rotation system and
so what i did
was during my first semester here i
actually just sort of worked informally
in a couple of groups
mainly just kind of doing informal
reading seeing what they were working on
getting a sense for what the research
was like and
and through that process i got a sense
of maybe which of the the two groups i
was looking at seemed like it would be a
better fit for me
and then uh started doing some very very
basic uh
low you know low time commitment
research with them during my first
academic year
here at yale it's uh you know the first
two years you teach and so that's what
supports you during the academic years
and so
similar to as emily said then it's nice
because you don't have to have the
pressure to be funded by your research
group during those first two academic
years
uh so you can you know put in as much
time as you're able while also focusing
on teaching
in classes and so it gives you a little
bit of a period to try out some
different research groups
i should say that not all programs work
this way i think there are some where
you're funded directly by research
groups or you can be as soon as you sort
of
set foot in the program so you know
looking at different programs and trying
to understand the different funding
models is
is actually something that can be
important and relevant to you as someone
potentially considering graduate school
because that can
definitely have an impact on your
experience or you know more generally
just the
flexibility you might have in exploring
different groups
yes spawning is the name of the game and
i'm gonna flash on my screen
if you go on any of the website of the
grad school usually you have a tab with
resources and the first thing that pops
in
is the funding and the grants because of
course you you need to be uh you need to
get your fundings there's
there's no need of going to grad school
if it's to just uh crash and burn
and then not having any money and uh one
thing that's uh that often pays is the
teaching
you talk about uh both of them talked
about that and we have a question in the
chat
um um somebody's interested in hearing
your thoughts on the teaching side
how much time does it take and do you
wish it was more teaching less teaching
what's the balance
uh is it uh yeah and so uh the person
said that teaching
teaching is not something that you
particularly enjoy oh sorry they
particularly enjoy
and um they are worried it's gonna be a
burden like can you give us the
the ratio of time to spend preparing
classes and cheating
i think that really depends on both the
class you're ta
and where you're doing it um i know that
at the u of a
you can be a grader so if you don't
enjoy standing up in front of people or
like
maybe you don't want to have those like
interactions like you there is the
option to be a grader in which case
um you never actually interact with the
students you just interact with the
professors
that however is my least favorite part
of teaching
and i also so i'm a slow grader and i
don't find it rewarding at all
so i much prefer when i'm teaching
labs and discussions but it i know that
in the physics department at the u of a
um the time commitment
uh varies so much depending on the class
because it'll be like if you're doing
discussions maybe you only really
need to do be there for the discussion
times but then there's not much to grade
or prepare ahead of time and then but if
you're doing labs you may have to like
help set up
and then grade the lab report it's a
great test so
um i know that they emphasize
that you shouldn't be doing um you
shouldn't be spending more than 20 hours
a week
on ta'ing because that's all you're
really getting paid for is you get paid
to be
a part-time teacher and then you either
part-time you're this
being a student but um i do know
that it can be difficult for some people
to balance
so if you can talk if i would recommend
that if you
get into a program perhaps talk to some
of the students there and they'll have
an idea of like what are the classes
that
would be work best for you um but i
really i really love tiang because i
always went to
grad school for like physics education
research so
now i'm funded through
my research so i don't need to ta but
instead i'm trying to come up with
nice outreach opportunities
so that i could still fulfill that like
part of myself
and you were trying to see something i
was just going to say that it really
depends
both the amount of teachings whether
it's 20 hours a week or 10 hours a week
the kinds of courses whether you're
leading a section or whether you're
doing grading really will depend on the
school
and the research group and so you know
physics
students may be asked to teach a
different amount
than computer science students say at
yale
so it really there's a great deal of
variety i think
um one thing to know is at least at yale
we have a
training program for first-time teachers
so people who may say oh my god i don't
know how i can't stand in front of a
classroom i i don't you know
that isn't me um there are a lot of
tools to help you become
a better teacher um but i'd also say
it also you know depending upon what
what program you enter
some programs won't allow students to
teach in the first year
some students start teaching their very
first year it really you
what you want to do is um you know do
your homework the nice thing is
everything's on the web you can usually
find out
when you go to the department that
you're thinking of joining
when the teaching is and at what level
and
if they have usually uh you're not just
thrown out into the
classroom and asked to sink or swim
usually there are people there to help
you
learn how to do this well and you may
find
that it's something that you didn't
think you liked but then there's a
particular aspect you really like
as emily said that she loves the in the
interpersonal aspect um but doesn't like
the grading
and you might find that actually you
find the grading or even just being
there sometimes
um tas are there to help answer
questions you know sometimes it's not um
you're not actually leading a section
you may find that one-on-one work is
something that you
really enjoy so i think there are
various forms of teaching
and whatever's ins you know whatever
program
and institution you're thinking of
joining you'd want to ask about that
what does it look like and what are the
different kinds of opportunities
available to you
it looks like somebody asked if you're a
ta do you need to develop your own
curriculum for the class
so i would say that's unlikely
i know at the u of a there's
opportunities
to be like a summer course teacher
in which case i assume you have more
like
control over the curriculum but i know
that in my experience it's been like
the uh worksheets and the lab books and
the labs and everything is already
set up and then you mainly just like
alter it so that
it like works for your students in the
room so like you would give an
introduction based off of what you think
they know
um or what they've like learned from you
in the previous labs and then
maybe you realize that you have a very
slow group so you like
might like take certain parts out that
are less important but that was
that was my experience so i think that's
less that you
create the curriculum and more of you
just kind of apply it to the
students i would add that i think that's
that's probably pretty typical i think
most programs know that not everyone
maybe is interested in doing a whole lot
of teaching or developing their own
materials and so
they probably try to minimize the amount
of time you would have to do that
certainly here at yale most of the
teaching assignments are
exactly the kind of thing emily
described but i will say on the flip
side of that if
you're someone who is interested in
teaching i happen to also be very
interested in teaching and have tried to
really make it an important part of my
graduate school experience
opportunities to for instance design
your own curriculum
can also be very exciting things so
those are some things i've sought out
and actually one aspect for me of my
graduate experience that i've really
enjoyed
is being in an environment where there
are a lot of resources surrounding
teaching so you can get involved in the
teaching community here more broadly
learn about how to be a better and more
effective teacher
and so you know whether teaching is a
plus or minus for you i think it's
certainly something that's worth
considering when looking at different
programs and important to bear in mind
all of the different
ways that it might affect your
experience for me it's been a huge
positive here i've you know joined
yale's center for teaching and learning
helping to teach other new graduate
students how to teach that's all
something i've really enjoyed but
for other people who don't like teaching
yale's also been a nice option as an
example
because the required number of teaching
hours per week is only 10 within the
first two years so comparatively i think
that's a fairly small number but
you know all sorts of different programs
are going to have different pros and
cons
it's really going to come down to doing
your research and seeing you know how
the particular program might fit with
your interest
go ahead i was just going to chime in
for a second so even though my
background's not related to quantum you
know going through grad school
i did a lot of teaching of lab sections
in geology since that's what my degree
is in
uh and i loved it i loved teaching as a
graduate student
and kind of speaking to the question of
developing your own curriculum
one of the ways that i actually got
funded was by helping develop the lab
curriculum
so it'll probably be a little bit
different engineering and physics but
there are those types of opportunities
where you can
definitely kind of shape the curriculum
if that's something you're interested in
but uh generally you're not expected to
just from my experience
all right that's good thank you all um
oh
go ahead do you want to see something
more sorry i saw that something that
said um
like if you do enjoy teaching like what
should you look for in a school
i was gonna say that if you see that
school has like a
professor who focuses on like physics
education research or something like
that
um that's probably going to be a
like incentivize going there because
like you know that they're going to be
keeping up with research and they're
going to be like willing to
like actually study what's going on um
in the classroom whereas
other schools may just kind of have
outdated materials which i know can
become
frustrating to have to teach even if you
enjoy teaching
one other quick detail on this point i
just mentioned is many schools will also
have
centers for teaching and learning which
could be a good contact point for you if
you are
interested in teaching they could tell
you what the experience is like and
resources you could find if you wanted
to further explore that interest
but that's not a thing that's present at
all schools so if you are interested you
know that would be a good sign in a
place you could find out more
and also depending on what you're going
to do with your phd if you want to join
industry teaching is not going to be as
important
as if you want to become a professor and
have your own group
because you will be required to create
curriculum and so it really depends on
what's your what's your career goal at
the end so it's something that you might
want
i know that five to six seven years is
like a long time but
you really need to come in with a plan
because um we
you might struggle to find the
motivation because it's a very long time
if you sort of don't know what the end
goal is you should not
really join a pg program just because
you get you get to be called a doctor at
the end which is great we love it
but it's a lot of struggle and there's a
ton of question in
in the chat about stress and struggle
and so and also a lot about the funding
maybe we're gonna go with the stress one
first we don't end up on a note too
bleak
but it's true that um a lot of a lot of
grad students
um have period of stress some um
some did with some depression uh is
there any tools that um
the grad school has in place to help
these kind of students
sure um i'm happy to take that and then
if conor and emily want to speak from
their personal experience
i think um graduate school is the best
of times
and the worst of times and um
it i think it's exciting because you're
you're focusing on exactly what you want
to think about and spend your time
thinking about and you're with
like-minded people but there's a lot of
pressure
to get things done in a timely fashion
research sometimes hits a dead end
there may be problems with an advisor
and then you know all kinds of life can
interfere
you can get sick um i think
when you're looking at graduate schools
first of all there are two things to
consider one is
you should always feel as though part of
your education
is asking for help no one knows how to
do graduate school until they've done it
so you just ask questions there's no
such thing
as a bad or a stupid question and you
could be asking them
of faculty you can be asking them of
your co-students so there may be an
older student that you
get to know but but never be afraid to
say
i don't know where to go to do x
or i'm interested in x where can i learn
more about it
or i'm really struggling with why um
do you have any suggestions about what i
might do or whom i might talk to
and i can't speak to every institution
but i would say most institutions have
an
office of student life who will help you
think about
you know how you bring together the
intellectual
and the personal side of you know
meeting people issues with housing those
kinds of things
many schools have really amped up their
mental health and counseling and i think
stress is
a big thing but they're also wellness
centers and so i think
knowing you know having a good sense of
when things are not going right for you
and
and not being shy about asking for help
and and um seeking counseling if you
need it
uh there's career services there's a
center for teaching and learning as
connor mentioned
there's a writing center at most places
so if you're struggling
you know to really put your ideas down
on paper
um that's a place to go um
and you know struggle can take any
number of different forms what i would
say is
almost every student will have some
challenge that they face
in the four to six years that they're in
graduate school
and that's not a sign that something's
wrong with you
that's just a sign that it's hard and i
think
that your job when you encounter a
challenge
is to find the right resources and if
you don't
know just ask as many people as you can
your director of graduate studies should
be able to help you with this
the dean's office should be able to help
you with this so you know if you
don't know where to start those are
often
good places to start there's no sort of
magic
formula but i think the main thing is to
know yourself
and know when you can't handle something
on your own
i think uh graduate school is set up
for people to ask for help that's why we
have all these other offices and no one
expects students to just magically know
how to do this you don't know how to
write a dissertation until you've
written a dissertation
so um i think the main thing is not to
be shy i would say the most successful
students take advantage of
all the resources that are available to
them and i'm going to stop there and let
connor and emily jump in and before you
do that
i i also want to point out that i've
been through grad school and
the the pattern that i've seen so is
that you start
very excited about it you're like you're
brand new students it's very nice
and then your your advisor can help you
because here's all the answers for now
because you still
learn about the field and then you
slowly realize that you're gonna start
to research a topic that
you are the only one or like one of the
few in the world who know the answer
and no no googling no book no anything
will help you because you are like on
the
on on the verge of knowledge and you
you're discovering new things
and it's it's also a very stressing time
because
you you feel that you're on your own and
then um this is what you need the
the help of all your all your colleagues
but also
you need to sort of internalize the fact
that it's it's a hard job and then
you're gonna um
you're gonna go through this is not uh
this is not too too difficult this is
pretty good and one thing that really
helped me is to find
mentor that can help you um often i've
realized that um the admins
and not the pis but like people helping
either some associate dean
some manager on in centers and people
like this
um working with students and doing
programming are usually very helpful um
when i was doing my phd in france
we had one of the one of the admin who
was
sort of like my confidence and when
something went wrong i just went
and and rants onto him and it was just
talking about it really helped um so
that's something that you should really
consider looking for mentoring and
asking for help like i
said how stressed were you during your
uh your pg at least conor that's now
that you're done you should look back
and be like oh that's nice and emily i
hope you're not too stressed yet
uh for me it definitely um like
oscillates
with stress like i've been more stressed
out in grad school than i've ever been
before
but then also there's just been lots of
external to grad school stressors that
are coinciding with you know trying to
get my masters and continuing the
program and things so
um you just have to like try to balance
that like
yes you want to get your phd
but you also need to like
live a balanced healthy life and like
the people
you know your advisors and your peers
and stuff should be
rooting for you um so do what you need
to do
to survive
but uh there are certain like stressors
that i've seen
um cause like friends of mine to
choose to not to continue with their phd
and instead of faster out of the program
and so i think those are important to be
aware of
uh so that you can maybe avoid them um
so some friends of mine maybe would
lose their funding so and that was the
only group that they were
interested in being in and so like it's
hard to
do a lot of serious research and ta and
do everything you know all at the same
time
um when you're not getting funding for
all like the
research work you're doing so that's one
thing is like
it is good to know and i think it is
okay to ask
professors if they have funding for you
um
like ahead of time and like how many
students maybe they're
expecting to take on in the future
and then uh also asking uh
other graduate students in the group
questions like this so
if you know there's a professor you want
to work with like you can maybe ask them
or you just directly email students in
the group
to see if they believe that there's
funding but also
if it's like a pleasant work experience
because there's lots of really
talented people out there who push their
graduate students very hard and they
have
very high expectations and maybe that's
not something that
you want um or like
can withstand um because you
are doing other things in your life and
you are taking classes and there are
other responsibilities
um and then also just being aware of
the like not only like the department
that you're
going to be joining but like the general
area of your
program so like i've had friends who
moved here to tucson who then realized
that
the jewish community isn't quite as
large as they'd like it to be and that
made their life very difficult and you
know maybe the u of a doesn't
take off certain holidays that they they
do
take off so then they're not able to
like have all the tools they think they
need to be happy on their own
let alone then to have to endure the
stresses of
the phd program so like it is important
like you i'm not saying you should
choose a school based only off of the
area it's in but that can be an
important
factor and if you are going to make it
through your program
i think the the issues that i'm hearing
from you and i think conor raised
earlier are
um community so making sure you have the
kinds of communities you're gonna need
to thrive so if you're someone who's
um uh very
religious and wants to ha and you know
make sure that there's a religious
community that
is either on campus or off campus that
is going to really be supporting you
um during these years and communication
which connor brought up earlier
um really trying to suss out
whether you are going to get on well
with your advisor and that you're going
to be able to talk
directly with them about
anything that arises and whether it's a
work-life balance
or um taking the research in a certain
direction
someone you feel you're going to be
comfortable
working with that's a one of the prime
ways
that you can avoid problems downstream
and sometimes that's tough to tell when
you're applying
i think sometimes you don't know until
you're there but it's certainly
something this is one of the reasons why
if
there are only one or two people at an
institution that you
think you want to work with you should
be talking to them
um before you even apply to see whether
their interpersonal style and yours are
gonna mesh
i'd add just one other quick comment on
this topic maybe before we move on
i wanted actually to emphasize some of
the things that ann and florian
mentioned earlier about the importance
of
knowing what resources are available to
you and asking for help when you need it
and so far as a mechanism to fight off
stress
so for instance in my own experience and
and many other graduate students
experiences one challenging thing to
deal with in graduate school can be
impostor syndrome as one example where
you feel like you know maybe your
research isn't exciting enough or you're
not doing well enough or you're not
smart enough to be in the program this
kind of thing
is it can be a common sentiment and i
think for me personally this is
something i struggled with early on in
the program
because i didn't realize uh all the
resources i had access to i wasn't
talking to the older members in my group
to try and get help when i was stuck on
problems
i wasn't uh you know leveraging some of
the other resources that were available
to me in my group and others in the
quantum center and so on and so i do
think you know i just wanted to
emphasize from personal experience that
uh knowing about the resources that are
available to you and
understanding that it is the expectation
that it takes time to
learn about a topic in a field and it's
okay to not know things and ask
questions and uh you know this is all
important things that everyone has to do
at some point so for me it took a while
to come to that realization and that was
stressful but um
uh you know having other people around
to help you through that it can be a
really important thing
okay we have uh a lot more question
about uh fundings
um so there's um there's difference
we're funding so we talked about how to
get funding through
ta but there's also fellowship and
anything connor
you had a fellowship with the nsf can
you talk
tell us a little bit more how um what
was the process
and um and how you got that one yeah
absolutely so most of my funding while i
was a graduate student
uh came through an nsf graduate research
fellowship and so
the way that worked was during it was
actually my second year of graduate
school i submitted an application during
the fall where i proposed the kind of
research i would be doing for my phd and
there were other components as well and
they came back and offered me funding
for
three more years after that so then in
the subsequent three years that is
where my funding came from so i didn't
have to
i didn't have to teach and i also didn't
have to ask my advisor to provide me
with
support out of one of their grants so
the nice aspect of something like that
is that it can give you a little bit
more flexibility to
uh work on whatever it is you're
interested in so when you have your own
funding source you can uh you know
go to potential advisors and say uh you
know i'm interested in this topic can
you work with me on this
and they don't have to worry about
finding money from a grant to help you
with it so it can give you a little bit
more flexibility in that way
and and so i think fellowships in that
regard can be a useful thing certainly
for you as a student
and you can apply for fellowships either
as an undergraduate to using graduate
school
or while you're in graduate school
usually an undergraduate institution
will have a fellowships office
and so you can start with them and then
often
the graduate school will have either an
office or
a site where you can look for
fellowships
that might be pertinent to you there are
a number of
sort of big name fellowships that many
people get like fulbrights which are to
travel
elsewhere and most campuses will have
somebody who can help you with that
i'd also say that the writing center
can help you with applications even if
there isn't a fellowship
office so there there are a lot of
different ways that you can find
funding but i want to repeat that if
you're applying to say an r1 institution
like yale um
you're going to get five years of
funding
um you know it may be that you have to
find a research group that will accept
you but
um there's there's
i would say there are very few instances
i know of where someone had to leave
graduate school because they had no
funding
so that's something to just reassure
people on you know
it's something that you want to be aware
of but
chances are once you have gotten into a
program
if it's an r1 a research one
institution unless you have a major
disagreement
with the single person who does research
in your area
um you should be okay
and there's also a lot more initiative
lately um the u.s government has created
these
national accounting centers we have hubs
everywhere and so these centers
have a lot of fundings and including in
the in the fundings that
they receive from the government they
have fellowships for uh
graduate students for postdocs and so
you might be able to
to go check on on these websites um
there's
also the national labs are often
associated with these herbs
these quantum herbs and so you might be
able to find different way to
to have resources i think the easiest
way is to get paid by the grad school so
you don't have to write anything so it's
sort of like the
the carefree thing it's it's not
available to anybody but there's also
other options and also i know um that uh
sometimes
um people can partner with a university
can partner with industry and the
industry will pay for
a chunk of the the funding so that's
also happens that happened also a lot in
europe there's
some this private uh government
partnership so that's also something
that you can consider uh depending on
where you want to go for grad school so
we're almost out of time i think maybe
uh what we can do
is we can take one last question talking
about the timeline
of applying to grad school like what are
the deadlines and what are the
the time that we need to go through so i
was just typing
an answer to that question because it
seemed like one
um what i would say is you our
application at yale opens in august
and depending upon the program um
it the deadline can be december 1st
december 15th or january 1st
and so if you are thinking of applying
you really want to have your materials
ready
you'll um i i this i can going to try
and fold
in another question which is what do you
need to do to apply but let me talk
about the timeline and then i'll try and
tell you the biggest pieces
of getting ready to apply um
so then usually depending upon the
program there may be an
on-campus visit that is arranged or a
virtual visit
and sometimes some schools do that
before acceptance decisions are made and
some schools do it after decisions are
made
and even that can vary within programs
usually
in early spring um
january and february decisions are made
and then graduate that the students who
have been admitted
have to make a decision by april 15th so
that's the
rough timeline but i would say go if
you're thinking of
specific schools you should go and look
at the school's website and they will
have
a more specific timeline the things that
you want to focus on in your application
are really research in the sciences
that's the key
issue and it's also the determining
issue for those
who really thrive in graduate school in
the sciences
faculty are looking for students with
prior research experience
and you want in your statement of
purpose which is different from an
undergraduate
personal statement to really answer
questions about
why why do you want to come to graduate
school
what are the questions or problems that
really interest you
what have you done to prepare to work on
these
and why is the institution that you're
planning to come to
or applying to the right place for you
to do this and that means
knowing who the faculty are and what
kind of research they're working on
so the statement of purpose is really
key and prior research
experience is also really key i would
say the third piece that's really
important is letters of recommendation
um because those are the and you want to
get them as strong
through at least three strong letters
from people who know your work have seen
you do research
and know you as a person and i could say
more about that but i notice the time
and i don't want to keep anybody
sounds good wait we're almost out of
time maybe uh while
i flash the the next event for uh for
the series
maybe we can go around and have a last
few words from each of you
and um the last advice that you can give
people considering grad school advice
broadly for people considering grad
school is a well very broad category so
i don't know that i can say something
that's going to
be of interest to everyone here but i
think one
one thing that for me was was very
helpful in this process was just
speaking to
students at the different programs i was
looking at you know
a lot of the questions i think have been
posed here are things that
people who have been through the program
can can readily answer for you and
really speak to how it affected their
experience whether these different
factors were positive or negatives
and so you know i think talking to
students as you look at different
programs is
should be a crucial determining factor
in you know gathering information so not
only can you talk to people about the
structure of the
the graduate program or the department
as a whole but you can also talk to
people
in a particular research group to get a
sense of what it's like to work with a
particular advisor
is the environment stressful what are
the expectations on students
you know i think this this is all
information you can gather before uh you
accept or even apply to certain programs
to try and whittle down your choices and
so
for me at least certainly this was
really valuable information and
for those considering graduate school i
would say if you're on the fence about
different programs or different areas of
research definitely talk to some of the
students there
they can certainly help point you in the
right direction
i think that
yeah i think that just even if you're
embarrassed to ask a question about
something like
it's better to ask and have someone um
hopefully answer it for you
so emailing professors if you want to
work with them emailing
um like other people who have positions
in the department stuff like that that's
a great way to
gather information and even just like
directly emailing
um students is a great way to get
information or if you can visit
um on-site like that's a like walking
around and talking to people in person
it's totally worth it and
uh but if you're emailing professors and
they aren't replying do not take it
personally i know that
lots of them just have so many emails
every day and like i have a hard time
getting
responses from my advisor sometimes
depending on how busy he is so
if you're really interested with working
with someone in particular
i would send follow-up emails and things
like that without thinking you're
bugging them or thinking that they're
ignoring you it's much more likely that
it's just lost in the stream of emails
they get
so i would say don't be afraid to aim
high
um you know ask a lot of questions
um do your homework and your research to
find out who's doing what where
and um don't be afraid to ask for help
uh at any stage along the way
i'll just echo what everybody else has
said it's really important to do your
homework in terms of
you know or do as much homework as you
can because once you make a choice
you know you're kind of there and you
want to make the best of it and
not have to switch or anything like that
so doing all your homework ahead of time
will
really help with all that and asking all
those important questions
perfect thank you very much all of you
thank you for all the attendees who
came in and asked the question this will
be recorded
and put later on on our website
um so you'll be able to have all the
answer again if you missed something
thank you all to your panelists and have
a good night